This is all of the work that I had done.
This is me getting off of
work driving to Chattanooga,
to do shows and going to work the next day
or driving to Asheville,
driving to Mobile, Alabama.
All of the stuff that I had
done up until that point.
This was me...
This was something for me going...
You're doing the right thing.
(upbeat music)
A lot of work goes
into a short late night stand upset.
Join me, J.P Buck,
as I spotlight that
comedians who came up with
some of my favorite comic sets.
This is, The Setup.
Please, welcome...
They're very funny.
Dulce Sloan.
(upbeat music)
So I think we had met at Bridgetown
and then we had met in 2015.
We met at Bridgetown
and I think I saw you again at JFL?
Yeah.
I'm very bad with names.
Very bad with names.
So you had called me
and asked me to be a part of...
Like a couple months later,
I was still back in Atlanta.
You had called me to do a
showcase for Turner at Flappers.
Mmh.
And you're like, " Hey,
Dulce, this is J.P.
And I was like, "hello."
I had no clue who the
hell was on my phone.
No, not a, not an inkling of
who the hell was on my phone.
And so you're like,
"yeah, I want you to do
this showcase for Turner."
I was like, "okay."
And so I just been out there the week
before to do Stand Up For Diversity.
And it was like to...
Like I had just quit my day job.
Like, I was like, "Jesus,
what am I going to do?"
I'm a ding dong.
I had no clue that you
were looking at get...
Like I was in...
I was auditioning basically
to do a late night set.
None, nothing, none, no clue,
I'm a ding dong.
So my manager calls me
at the end of January
and he's like, "hey, listen,
just heard from J.P."
I was like, "Oh, that's nice."
He was like, he's like,
"are you sitting down?"
I was like, "I can be."
He was like, "so you're doing Conan."
And I was like, "yeah."
He's like, "in two weeks."
And I was like, "what?"
(upbeat music)
The set that I had in mind
when I was doing my set,
I was like, I just need to be this good.
And it's Solomon Georgio's set.
That's the set I had in my mind
when I was getting ready for this.
And he did it a year before me.
But I was like...
And I had never met Solomon before.
Cause I hadn't moved to LA yet.
And now me and him were
really good friends.
But I remember seeing him like everybody.
I remember everybody talking
in Atlanta,
talking about Solomon's set
and that's the set that I had in mind.
And I was like, "I just
need to be this good."
And then he ended up...
He posted it after I did it.
He was like, "you know,
this is the best way
to celebrate my one year anniversary
of me doing Conan."
And he posted my set and
I was like, "hah, hah."
(upbeat music)
Shout out to your
hairdresser, who did my afro?
We started hairdressing,
and me and my manager looked at each other
and we see this white
woman standing there.
And he was like, "can you style an afro?"
She goes, "I learned how
to do hair in the 70s."
And I was like, "she's fine. She's fine."
(laughs)
I wanna give credit to whoever...
Oh, I might cry.
I don't know who the stage hand was,
who opened the curtain
and handed me the microphone.
But when I finally got back there
and I was just like, "okay."
And he just...
He's holding the microphone
and he's on the curtain.
He goes, "you got this,
done this 1000 times.
You're fine. You know your markets."
And I don't know who this man is,
but I will give him a baby.
If he asked me.
Like that,
he kinda like,
kinda knocked me back into place.
And I was like, "I'll give him a kid
If he asked me."
That's all I'm saying.
(upbeat music)
I know y'all are wondering,
"why can I see this big chick's bra?
(audience laughs)
Simple question, simple answer.
This bra was 100 dollars.
(audience applauds)
That's it.
Cause if I pay a 100 dollars for anything,
you're gonna see it.
(audience laughs)
My mother asked me to
wear high waisted pants.
So my tummy did not show.
I did not care.
She said, but it'll give them...
She said,
it'll bring more emphasis.
She said, if she the...
if the right skin is showing,
then you'll bring emphasis to
where you wanna bring emphasis to.
You're dressing in this way
that has people thinking
and questioning something.
And you were answering
that question right away.
Worth me going, listen,
you see these titties.
They're out here.
Take it in, breathe them in, live in it.
And it was just me kinda signaling like,
"listen, I'm having fun.
Listen, this is a great opportunity.
And you know, y'all are enjoying the show,
but we gonna have fun."
And that's what I wanted to convey
because the thing is,
I'm not having fun,
they shall not gonna have no fun.
Now its got an issue with
gay men grabbing my boobs,
especially at brunch.
(audience laughs)
You're sitting there drinking mimosa.
All of a sudden,
boom gay man's hand right here.
(audience laughs)
Pulsing.
Looking you in the face, going,
"Oh, girl it's all right, I'm gay.
(audience laughs)
It's why you can't do it.
Cause no one puts the
keys in a Lamborghini,
starts the car and gets out.
(audience laughs)
(audience claps)
So if you grab a boob,
you having sex with me, gay man.
(audience laughs)
That's a TV friendly version of that joke.
Yes.
The version that you've been doing
in clubs and festivals,
which is not TV clean,
No.
You do use different words.
You use the f-word in that joke.
We have to make it TV friendly, period.
but we didn't lose...
We didn't lose the
essence of the joke just
because I had to say sex instead of (beep)
like it didn't...
I didn't lose anything from it.
(upbeat music)
its not gay, men grabbing my boobs,
they got white women putting
their hands on my afros.
(audience laughs)
see a couple of perpetrators in the room.
Cause they're not classy
when they put their hand in your afro,
they don't wanna stay on
the perimeter of the afro.
She don't wanna keep it Christian, no.
She takes her whole hand,
goes straight to the scalp,
shake it back and forth
and then exit your afro
with this jellyfish action.
(audience laughs)
While she's looking at her friend going,
"Lauren it's so soft
(audience laughs)
its like a poodle, its so soft."
Poodle, really?
Now, rubbing my fingers
through your blonde hair going,
"Ooh, it's like a golden retriever."
(audience laughs)
(audience claps)
Its rude.
I love your line at the beginning
of keeping it Christian.
(laughs)
It's one of my favorite things to say.
I love that.
It obviously...
it doesn't, really make sense in that...
In what you're saying.
However, it's such a fun thing to hear.
Yes.
And like, I just...
Its like, it's just...
Its really...
It adds so much to the joke.
You know, out here just
keeping it a Christian.
You know, it's so funny to me.
And it's a ridiculous statement
because people go,
"what does Christianity
have to do with her hair?"
That's the point.
It's ridiculous.
It's a joke.
It makes me happy.
But I would...
When I started doing
that line in that bit,
I always got a bigger laugh
than whatever I was saying before.
How'd you settle on Lauren?
I came up with that joke
because there was one time at the...
When Atlanta had an improv.
This woman comes up to me after the show
and says...
they're really drunk,
like 50 something year old, white lady.
And she's yelling at her friend,
"Lauren, she's just like Adelaide."
I was like, "what's happening?"
And she's like, "Oh," she's like,
"you just remind me of
the woman who raised me."
And I was like," I
didn't need any of that."
And it was her trying to touch my hair
and all of this other goofy nonsense
and her husband just comes out of nowhere.
He's like, "I'm so sorry,
I'm so sorry. She didn't..."
Cause when he...
Cause she was talking to me,
trying to touch my hair,
so I'm dodging that
and she calls Lauren over
and then Lauren's like,
"I don't think you should be..."
She's like, "no, it's okay.
No, I don't know."
And then she and her husband's kinda like,
"Hey, come on in."
And its like,
"Oh, my g...
You remind me of the lady who raised me."
And her husband goes,
"all right, gotta go."
And then just yet like cartoon,
Sandman on the Apollo,
just yanks this woman back.
And that's how I kinda
came up with that whole bit
because of her friend's was
name was actually Lauren.
I'm just like,
I have had white women
come up to me and go,
"Oh my God, is that why that lady
at my job doesn't like me?"
and I go, "yes.
Because you keep touching...
Quit touching her,
with touching her hair...
But she said, but it's
different all the time."
Fine.
That doesn't mean you need to touch it.
And then, men specifically,
usually white men, going,
"that doesn't happen to you."
I'm like, What?
"The people don't come
up and touch your hair."
I was like,
"people touch women all
the time, all the time."
There's always some
dudes skirting past you.
Going like, "excuse me."
Putting a hand on the small of your back
or somewhere on you.
People touch women all the time.
And then people touch black
women's hair all the time.
So the fact that I had
men coming up to me going,
"that's not happening to you."
Like yes,
yes it is.
It was always a craziest reaction.
So I either got white women apologizing
or white men saying to me,
"this didn't happen."
So I was like,
"okay, I have to put
this joke in this set."
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
That's hilarious.
Thank you so much.
That's Sloan, ladies and gentlemen,
He was saying how funny I was
and he was just like,
"if you need anything,
you know, let us know
if you ever wanna come back on the show,
let us know."
And I was like,
"he didn't have to say that."
So, I knew, it was g...
He was, he was just telling me,
he like,
"you're so funny.
And I really enjoyed watching you."
And I was like,
"Oh man."
Like I just,
I didn't expect him to say all that stuff.
So when I walked off stage, I was like,
I just didn't cry.
And like that's when I
let everything hit me.
That's when everybody
got to know who I was,
I've done two pilots.
I've had, I just,
I'm doing a movie that...
I just did a movie this year
and it's coming out in November.
Conan was kind of the
springboard for everything.
So I'm so thankful to y'all
for just being supportive of me.
It's a small little like
calling card for you.
But I just knew that
this was like starting
an unstoppable force
and I'm so happy just
to see what you've done.
I should have been fired
if I didn't book you.
That's all I could say.
Oh, thank you.
It was the easiest,
like the easiest decision
when Reggie emailed me,
I was like,
"Oh yeah. Okay, let's do this."
Oh, thank you.